all right um Freddie yes Freddie uh
where you from Earth
where'd you grow up so I was born in
Kuwait
my dad is Lebanese my mom is Armenian
but we moved here when I was three so to
Boston so I grew up in Boston in Good
Charlotte great childhood mom and dad
were together since they were teenagers
my dad was a contractor my mom was a
stay-at-home mom
Catholic upbringing you know did their
the altar boy you know first communion
all that good stuff yeah it's a bigger
thing for Boston right yeah and so you
left home at what age I was 13 or left
home they had a little issue with my dad
and it was either him or I he was be was
becoming kind of too abusive towards my
mom and I stood up to him he is from the
generation where one of us had to give
and I wasn't given he wasn't given so
that's 13 you you were left home I I
used to hang out with people older than
me and we had a neighbor two doors down
my Italian friend I lived in an Italian
neighborhood in Boston back in those
days he either had Irish Italian like
whatever neighborhoods you know solid
and Roslindale which is predominantly
Italians so a friend of mine which was
19 at the time it looked like two doors
down from us so I just stayed with them
stayed in the in their station wagon
they had a woody so I did I roughed it
up for about a couple of months and then
but I still went to school that was
embedded in us graduated at 16 went to
college went to UMass started working at
18 as a restaurant manager and which was
the only job I've ever had working for
somebody so yeah that's basically it -
went to college and graduated and worked
as a restaurant manager and then I
decided to move out west in 85
California yeah I came to San Diego I
was an amateur competitive bodybuilder
at the time so I wanted to move out here
you know because Arnold was big and
pumping high and all that so I wanted to
come out to Venice and compete and
bodybuilding live that lifestyle and
that's what I did and then at some point
you got into owning brothels so do you
want me to talk to you about how that
happened yeah how I became that yeah
guys that even started if he had told me
back then that I'll be doing that at the
time I would have said there's no way
but what happened was I got into the
nightclub business right
and that became one third owner of a
nightclub called diego's which was
really popular back in the days in
Pacific Beach in California and I would
have customers come in get drunk you
know how guys are and every once in a
while at least once or twice a week to
go go we had really beautiful gorgeous
waitresses right and bar mates and they
had them in really short miniskirts I
don't know if you remember the 80s but
back then everything was miniskirt right
and the guys will ask me hey you know
can I go out with this girl you know and
they'll start offering money I'm like no
man you can't ask me go ask her you know
I wasn't even on that plane I wouldn't
want to talk about it I didn't I didn't
want to know anything about it they're
just it's between you and her I bought
my own club in rich crest it was the
only club in town and the same thing
happened I've always had really
good-looking
I've always hired could look and help
you know mostly 99% women because I like
I love women so I want to be around
woman and the same thing happened guys
would ask me hey can I go out with
so-and-so can I go out with a DJ kind of
a man just go ask her
so now fast-forward to 94 when I moved
to Hawaii I had an opportunity to for
walla showroom in Waikiki so I knew this
guy that they had a show down there
called legends in concert which they
have at Imperial Palace I know if they
still have it now but so his name was
Marvin Silverman he said you know I have
this comedy show I don't want to do
anything with
showroom but I haven't another two years
on the lease if you want to take it over
and you can do some sort of a show there
so started the show I called it Island
dolls I stole a the the hostess of the
show or the start of the show from
another show because she was already
well-known down there so the show was
called Island dolls and the same thing I
would have celebrities come in and they
would it was basically like the show is
called
crazy girls in Las Vegas which is
basically like a topless review and you
have a bunch of like 12 girls on the on
the dance on the stage and the start of
the show singing dancing cracking jokes
whatever emcee so I would have few
celebrities come in and every once in a
while they would ask hey can I go with
so-and-so can I go with so-and-so the
funny part is we had a certain celebrity
who's it was still pretty a celebrity
stoled today and he liked the star of
the show now at the time they started
showing myself who became Gulf and a
boyfriend right he didn't know this so
he offered 20 grand to sleep with the
girl right I wasn't in love with her I
just wanted it to stay with the show
because she was the heartbeat of the
show right
she still she was living with me at the
time so I went up to her and I said hey
yeah so and so she said yeah I saw him
he's in the front row whatever I said
well he just offered 20 grand you know
to sleep with you I wanted to see a
reaction you know she's like oh no I
don't know because you know you and I
together I said look if I I don't care
it's up to you that's 20 grand you know
I was saying her up she said well if
it's okay with you of course you know I
learned real quick and every everybody
has a price right and she was a Vegas
girl to begin with so that was the first
time I have ever had that kind of
transaction and I allowed it you know of
course she went and they did whatever
they did she came the next day in 20
grand cash you know and that was a hook
you know big money sometimes hook you so
it's definitely a hug and from then on
I'm in there
into Vegas and subtle limo service
everybody's asking me more about girls
than the stupid limo and I'm like screw
the limos limos free you know here's the
girls and it just went on and then I I I
met this girl her name is Lisa storm she
was a penthouse pet and she had just
began building her own website
this is 1998 and I had never heard I've
been online twice didn't know anything
about it
didn't know what an emo was she says she
started showing me what she was doing
beautiful girl penthouse bad making good
money so I said you know what this is a
really good thing so I stuck with this
goal became girlfriend boyfriend and
that's how I got introduced to online
escorting and it was amazing it was such
a breakthrough because now I don't have
to because I was doing the limo thing I
don't have to actually do it in person
I can promote the business from from
home or whatever so that was a big
revelation to me and then you can of
course scale it as many times as you
want see it at home with your underwear
whatever I'm like wow this is great so I
took it around with it I basically
trained myself how to do websites how to
promote online how to place the ads
where to place the ads how to screen
through emails how to screen through the
phones and I trained with Lisa and
actually she was she went from like 20
or 30 grand a month when she was doing
it by herself and towards the end four
years later she was bringing in between
120,000 just from the escorting part
because I felt end up building like
three different websites for her and
yeah so she did not want me to work with
anybody else and of course I wanted to
make more money so I split up with her
and started my own agency and couple
years later I had over 220 girls and 33
foreign girls
I got a license it's called out core
promotor license
and that's also a misconception about
Vegas said it was legal it's never legal
right either on this trip which is Clark
County hell or downtown Las Vegas which
is the city of Las Vegas where they have
an intent law meaning as long as you
show up as long as the girl shows up at
even at valet they can bust her they
don't have the elements that is required
in the state of California for example
you should have to have sex for money
that doesn't happen in Vegas as long as
you show up and greet say oh yeah boom
done so and that's what happened and
Vegas is a completely different thing
then then anywhere else as far as the
business model you have alcohol which is
the girl goes to the client or in call
which is the client comes to the girl's
location in Las Vegas it was a 99.9
percent alcohol because most of our
client clientele there were
professionals in town for two or three
days just for a convention for some sort
of business meeting or a conference they
had to own hotel room and they felt
safer in their own environment and they
would just call us when they're done
with their work and hanging out with
their buddies and colleagues and doing
the dinners or whatever so we worked
phenomenally from 5:00 p.m. to 5:00 a.m.
seven days a week and that was mainly
our target market which is that one
person ninety nine point not here's a
spoiler alert ninety-nine point nine
percent of the clients throughout thirty
years of this is they're married or
attached or have a boy a girlfriend
boyfriend some of them did that too but
um so yeah that's how it all progressed
how do you pick up 220 girls where do
you find them in Vegas was really easy
Vegas just the way Vegas is and the
energy it has and the vibe it attracts a
lot of those type of girls that want to
get into either stripping or they are
you doing stripping and they go to the
next level in the VIP room then end up
calling somebody like me to work
because they see how much money is
involved and usually what happened with
me is I treat the girls really really
well and I was really fair with them I
most of the most of the time I give them
50% of everything that they brought in
and some people might say well that's a
lot of money to you but really they have
they come in with zero experience zero
investment zero done everything costs
money as you know business costs money
ads cost money for girls costs money
you're gonna pay them ten percent so
they made really good money and the
average was about fifty or sixty grand a
month for each girl so one girl would do
so well and she was treated really nice
by the we had a really good screening
system which is another very important
thing in this business the most
important thing other than hiring the
right girls so you had to be very
careful of picking the right clients
it's not not all money it's good money
you don't want to let money walk but you
only want good money to come in so we
focused on that professional you know
that I explained before and the girls
will bring other girls I had a lot of
students a lot of extra pers a lot of
them came to Vegas with her husband or
boyfriend and things didn't work out and
somebody ends up being on drugs or what
have you and they ended up with me we
were drugs a big part of the picture I
am totally against drugs I have zero
tolerance for drugs is I think drugs is
drama drugs to me equal drama I've never
done drugs I don't do drugs I probably
smoked weed once in my life did ecstasy
maybe twice even when I sold coke before
I started doing this business that's how
I got the money to get the nightclubs I
I never I never was into drugs you know
but um in Vegas it was difficult not you
had to turn a blind eye because the
majority of the girls I would say over
50% did indulge whether it's coke
crystal meth ecstasy
heroin you name it so what I did is I
tried to make sure they didn't do it at
work or with clients as much as I can of
course you can't control everybody now
when we get to the Orange County part
that was completely different that was a
completely different business model
there was a completely different setup I
had changed a lot of my ways and I
wanted to really clean operation did you
want me to expand on that so what
happened was I had a problem in 2006
with the feds they try to get me on
money laundering tax evasion because
they couldn't get me on the other thing
so and I was a talent agent for welcome
studios at the time I was the resident
talent agent for six years so we had Sin
City talent agency so what they did was
they indicted me and you know they can
indict a ham sandwich really and I just
bought one plus one okay here you go
here you got indictment and I sat for 31
months in North Las Vegas jail which
they were they held the federal B trial
detainees at the time the Las Vegas does
not have an MCC because it's a small
town and it took me 31 months no bail of
course and I beat him I got out and by
that time they had taken everything now
by me bringing him back I had lost a lot
of the value of a lot of things that I
had for example like that they took
seven cars of mine and took him from Las
Vegas to Long Beach for the US Marshals
so they can do the if I had lost the
case they would have just auctioned them
off
well it's cost me over 36 grand to bring
my own cars back to Las Vegas that they
take in the first place it's just you
know it's a whole mess so I was really
short on cash I tried a couple different
businesses legal businesses and to be
honest with you it was too rough and the
money you get helped on the money at
least I was on really good money in Las
Vegas I never did less than two or three
hundred thousand a month you know that
was just average
sometimes you did over a million and
this is just for me you know not gross
and so it's tough it's tough to go from
that to nothing and even when I had
businesses that were making twenty
thousand a month it just wasn't enough I
had given my got myself used to a
assumed lifestyle which is a trap right
I'm dealing with that right now
so by 2012 I was pretty much I had I
think $1,300 left to my name I said okay
so this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
move to Orange County because I was I
was thinking about moving to a Newport
Beach anyways I had some friends over
there that kept telling me hey move over
here that's where the money is
blah blah blah and I love the area I
said okay I'm gonna give myself five
years or a certain amount of money which
was eight figures right whichever one
comes first
I'm done I'm retired Bora Bora Costa
Rica whatever I'm done right so this was
in 2012 which I was 49 I've always
thought I'd retire you know early but it
doesn't work that way when kids if
you're watching this when you do solve a
legal but there's no such thing as easy
money easy money is the hardest money to
make going back to Orange County so I
said okay five years or X amount of
dollars let's say ten million dollars
just for the sake of this video so I
started by doing yummy
I called him yummy parties everything
was pink and nice and bubbly and
basically what I did was I I wanted to
test the market see what kind of people
are living in there in the area what
kind of clients have it was different
model because in Vegas everybody came to
Vegas for business and that was my
client in Orange County the locals were
my client because a lot some people came
to Orange County but it's mostly I have
to depend on the locals so a friend of
mine she used to do the fashion shows
and lingerie
shows she had a she's from Newport Beach
and she had like a good list of over 650
clients so we put together yummy parties
basically I went to Orange and they had
a lot of big mansions over there in
orange and I rented one and we promoted
it for about a month it was a masquerade
thing and so everybody can have a mask
because it's one of those things that
people don't want to you know be exposed
so I said okay great it's around the
Mardi Gras so we'll make a make it like
a masquerade party and we had a really
nice huge probably like twenty-five
thirty thousand square feet mansion with
a big pool in the back a nice circular
driveway
it had a big iron gate in the front
everything was gated so I had security
at the gate everybody had to RSVP with a
pseudonym you know wet dog or white you
know sky or whatever so nobody have to
use their name we knew who they were
so they come in they on the list on the
tablet come on in everybody's dressed in
tuxedos all the security guys and
everything I had valet come in a circle
a drive a drop dropped them off to a
couple of girls came out with nice nice
long sexy gowns and escorted them to the
main doors huge doors had two big guys
open the doors this the whole Eyes Wide
Shut episode right now the same type of
atmosphere and they came in he have the
two big staircases and came in had a
nice big bar set up all the girls were
in lingerie I had over 95 girls most of
them are models I hired models legit
models they're like Victoria's Secret
models and stuff and of course I have
the girls that will do anything they ask
or type so the way I had it set up
they'll come in and they get seated let
me go get a drink
I had a cocktail waitresses topless the
old topless the bar maids were topless
come in all gorgeous girls get their
alcohol and we we made sure we had
everybody's RSVP'd for what they want
life to eat and drink and everything was
really upscale and we had a deejay and
and a dance floor DJ was topless before
you he asked me yes she was topless
right and downstairs in the wine cellar
we turned it into a dungeon like a
domination dungeon so I had a couple of
really hot girls in like cat kind of
pleather suit you know that sweater with
the whips or whatever and the whole
cross thing and they were doing each
other with a you know S&M and being he
just soft self domination and of course
guys could participate and then going up
to the second floor on the right side we
had a we called it a VIP area which is
behind closed doors there's a huge area
as big as your studio maybe bigger and I
had a stay set up with a girl girl go
show every couple of hours so like 9
o'clock 11 o'clock 1 o'clock 3 o'clock
so it was a girl on girl and girl show
with whipped cream and dildos and strap
ons and you name it right and that was
basically to give the guys something for
their $500 it was $500 to get into the
door everything's included it brings the
food we had a really nice buffet set up
downstairs you know lobster and filet
mignon whatever they wanted it was all
nicely catered and the whole idea was
the guys go upstairs they see the show
or they go downstairs or whatever of
course they're gonna get horny guys will
be guys right it's not that difficult to
get that blood traveling down south so
get them upstairs they see the show now
we on the other side of upstairs we had
five bedrooms suites with each one had
their own bathrooms really beautiful
very very well decorated and so we had
our goals for that and they will Kelly
would go and Kelly was my friend that
helped me with this she would go and set
up the guy with their girl that was her
job see which which guy wanted which
girl and what
girl he wanted she knew all her clients
already so we did really good
we had over 320 guests at the time and
after everything I think I I made after
everything was paid for the place the
girls I don't know I made sure everybody
was paid really well because you want to
keep people happy you want anybody
flapping their mouth was your gonna do
anyways so I ended up with about fifty
between fifty and seventy I can't really
remember exactly but for one night it
was not bad for a month thing and Kelly
Kelly made about 25 or 30 anyways I
ended up doing that one more time then I
stopped it because girls were coming in
that I didn't know who the hell they
were they wanted to work as other girls
told them you can't control the stuff
clients were coming bringing ten people
with them which they're not supposed to
it was just getting out of control and
you wanted to be a you know flash news
on the five o'clock news where you know
we get busted for whatever so I decided
to start my agency and before I went to
get went ahead in least places to make
them into brothels I wanted to test the
market so what I did was I would I hired
two girls at first that they have places
and figured out the market the market
was good it was enough to sustain what I
wanted to do to get the amount of money
I needed to make so we went from that to
six girls not hired the girls that
didn't have places to to work out of so
I had to use hotel rooms at first so I
would use like the Hilton across street
from the John Wayne Airport or they
Hyatt on Jamboree in 405 really nice
nice places around everything was around
Irvine because it's a it's a perfect
area it's not a Newport Beach because
it's very conservative so I want to make
sure I'm out of Newport Beach but also I
want that access so that it can come in
and go real quick a lot of people work
in Irvine a lot of people living on and
you put beach or Laguna Beach
so that was a really nice central
location well there's also a lot of
businesses there and that was my target
market is that professional that works
and all lives in the area and made sure
the hours were convenient for them so we
worked 11:00 a.m. to 7 p.m. Monday to
Friday so we had bankers hours just like
there's this way they have the
opportunity to come and do their thing
and go back to work or go home and
nobody would know because their wife or
their significant other will think
they're at work so I did everything I
could to help them out that way yeah I
facilitated the whole thing anyways so
once I did the proof-of-concept at the
hotels I decided to start getting places
permanent places so I ended up start
hiring girls with somewhat good credit
so I can get the places in their name
and started lease in places right around
that area all upscale places usually one
bedrooms that's all we needed because
each girl was assigned to one place per
day so I went from 6 to 8 to 10 I maxed
out at 12 signed it up with 12 places
with 12 girls each day five days a week
I only let the girls work two or three
days so I ended up having to have about
65 or 70 girls on the roster to be able
to fill all the slots and what I did was
I
I brought a interior decorator and made
sure those places were decorated really
nice and beautiful and each place had a
different motif and color themed and the
other one this way nobody got bored
especially the clients so always
everything I did it was with the clients
in mind what would the client like I put
myself in their position and I hired
beautiful girls 21 and older made sure
that their overage check their IDs of
course some of them I have to do a
background check because they looked so
damn young because I you know I don't I
don't believe that you should work with
anybody under 21 there's just my honest
opinion
so the predominately they were between
21 and I would say 35 and girls are in
their 30s they were in really good shape
they're all beautiful they're nines and
tens on the beauty scale from one to ten
ten being extremely beautiful because we
were charging 500 an hour minimum so you
have to make sure that you can justify
that hourly rate and I'll make sure that
they've never done it before because I
didn't want to have them come in with
bad habits or people that want to just
come and steal clients
which some of them of course try to do
or the ones that want to hustle the
client which I didn't allow I made sure
that there are those clients for my
clients so I wanted to make sure that I
keep them very happy because the girls
are expendable you can always change
them doesn't matter to their guys some
guys maybe one or two percent again to
fall in love which is another whole
different story but for the most part
they wanted a beautiful girl with
beautiful body that did a good job so no
drugs over 21 either going to school and
they had to tell me something positive
that they needed the money for whether
they want to play pay student loans
which was about 75% of the girls I
worked with a few of them that had a bad
divorce with kids single moms they
needed the money some of them wanted to
save for a business some of them wanted
to buy a home I had few of them that was
very sad when I checked I always check
on everything fact check make sure that
you know unfortunately being in that
world for so long you get a little jaded
so you always got a fact check make sure
that somebody's not trying to pull
something over you I remember this girl
she worked at in-and-out burger and she
was going to school and her mom had
stage four cancer and she did not have
the health insurance that covered so I
let her work unfortunately this wasn't
for her so I I basically told her that
she should really shouldn't do it
because she was getting depressed and
everything you know
so I always made sure that if you know
it's not for everybody not everybody can
do this you know there's a separation
between Lisa the person and Krystal the
escort right we use this different name
because it's like this is like stripping
right it's not you doing it it's just a
psychological thing but some girls they
can't separate and they can't do it so
and I always let them know look man we
shouldn't be doing it and I didn't I
didn't let him work the same girl came a
month later and she tried to work well
can I just let me just work a few days I
can make the bills of like no remember
last time you were you know you were
very depressed you you didn't know it
was not for you you did not feel good
about yourself and if you can't feel
good about yourself with what you do no
money in the world is gonna fix that so
forget about it so that's what I did you
had to have something positive never
done it before so I wanted to train them
exactly how I wanted to train them to be
nice to the customers I basically did
this job as I would run a fortune 500
company I wanted the same type of
employee good work ethic I know it
sounds weird because this field but it
could happen I did it good work ethic
loyal integrity honesty no lying I hate
lying so I told I will not lie to you do
not lie to me and that was the kind of
relationship I had and I try to help him
as much as I can I give him 50% of
everything and some of them would say
wow that's a lot of money in my thing
would be okay well do you want to keep
hundred percent while you're making
right now and you want to make fifty
percent of this much since you're making
this right and also they come in no
experience I have to get the clients I
mean I work 17 or 18 hours a day seven
days a week and the reason why I did
that is I made sure I was the only
person behind the scene because I've
been told down before that federal case
I told you about in Vegas one of my foam
girls actually took one of my laptops
and after I fired and went to the feds
so I didn't want that to happen to me
again as I said you know there's only
one way to do it one-man show I can only
handle so much even though I'm really
good at what I do but I want you to
imagine this you got 12 places one girl
in each place and I had to be in between
every single transaction
we averaged between say six at a minimum
sometimes up to ten transactions per
location per girl right and I'm in
between every single transaction so you
can only imagine and imagine when before
I had accumulated the clients and once I
got the clients it wasn't as bad because
I already know the clients I don't have
to screen them the screening is what's
what's what's the killer out of every
hundred calls I might like to I'm very
very picky right it's gonna be a certain
kind of guy that'll be over thirty five
used to be over forty but they kept
getting younger as because it's more
accepted now to go out with an escort
over thirty five professional have their
own business or CEO or entrepreneur or
VP of a company and I have to be able to
verify who they are and I have my ways
of course it's all about the screening
so imagine screening and keeping
everything going with twelve spots and
you only want person that's why I worked
17 18 hours a day I know you can relate
to that because he gotta be the
videographer photographer you do the web
designer you're gonna do all the
advertising guy you're gonna be the
marketing the promotion's they're gonna
be the security the screening the the
CPA right one man know everything yeah
you know where I were I'm sure you do
too 25 hats right so that's why I tapped
out at 12 anyways it was enough money
after everything was paid I put away
fifty a week so I wasn't bad five days a
week but I worked seven right because
Saturdays was for for video shoots photo
shoots interviews and I did two or three
per week always two or three yeah I I
got my clients really hooked on new
girls so I had to make sure I keep that
supply coming just like a drug
cuz to be honest with you most of them
were sex addicts and didn't even know it
so Monday to Friday I would wake up at
five go to the gym be in the office by
seven
even when I'm doing cardio I'm doing
emails and setting up appointments and
everything else and by eleven o'clock I
have pretty much 70 80 percent of the
bookings for the day for each girl
I would turn them over once I have the
client see one or one girl or two girls
or three girls you know at least two or
three times and I know that they're our
type of client which meaning that they
are professional there at the right age
I prefer them between 40 and 55 or 60
they're very nice they treated the other
two three girls nice the one that they
thought they were independence I turned
him over to my oath my place was called
OSI fund my business so I turned them
over to the one website where all the
girls are on that website instead of
just having a whole bunch of websites
everywhere this way made it easier for
them look man this is what's going on we
got together this is why I sold it us
girls got together and we put this
together
it's a username password protected
website it's very secure and safe and
discreet and you're a VIP now which made
them feel better right they're part of
our thing it's an exclusive club and so
it was just you know all the girls under
one roof and it showed the schedule a
each girl when she's working so the guys
can see all the old businessmen all
professionals so they had to make sure
that they can fit it in their schedule
because I had a lot of doctors at about
five or six hundred doctors that maybe
as many lawyers I had a lot of
entrepreneurs CEOs a couple of
billionaires a whole bunch of
millionaires and a and a lot of junior
millionaires in that area so I was
really lucky I ended up with eighty six
hundred clients eighty six hundred
yes twelve places eighty six hundred
clients just in Orange County
miss Orange County here Wow yes and what
percentage were married of the clients
yeah ninety nine percent maybe ninety
nine point three percent this overnight
deficit so when I hired the girl I made
a deal with her so I'll give you an
example I had a girl that went to UCLA
and she wanted to become a dentist
she owed 150 thousand
and student loans and she really wanted
to pay it off
this girl was gorgeous she was a
Victoria's Secret model she was half
Scandinavian half Korean just gorgeous
tall beautiful body amazing and I
couldn't believe she was doing this she
is so gorgeous and I said okay so let's
call her Sarah we're gonna do this for a
year maybe six months because she can
only work two days at the time I let him
work more than two days a week but she
can only work two days a week I said
maximum a year maybe six months get you
in and get you out and that's what I did
with all the girls you know I will first
hire them okay we need the money for
make sure it's something positive I'm
not gonna hire somebody that's on crack
I'm not nothing against anybody I'm just
not gonna support bad habits I had a
really bad experience in Las Vegas so I
learned from my lesson to pay attention
and this is why I don't really like
drugs in this business so each girl came
in we figured out what you need the
money for how long it will take just
from experienced I got her in and got
around why because I noticed after years
of the six this this business that if a
girl does it over a year it's the point
of no return of coming back to ever be
able to be normal or do something else
it really it's this irreversible damage
that happens to that person at that
point plus the the addiction to that
kind of money it's it's crazy I mean I'm
addicted to that kind of money myself to
be honest so I didn't want him to fall
in that trap so I always had good
intentions towards them and I want to
make sure that I give him the best
advice that I can as a friend and a
co-worker because I don't want the bad
karma so
let's see what else we're going to talk
about so basically I ended up with
eighty six hundred clients twelve places
everything was going great
so mostly that that's what I was dealing
with I kept it really honest the clients
they're all happy they couldn't believe
they had such a safe environment for
them to come to some really clean all
the places were decorated really nicely
showers everything towels everything was
just beautiful they had music and
candles and since everything was just
perfect the girls were happy clients
were happy Coles were happy clients were
happy it's gone no complaints I did that
for four and a half years finally around
May of 2000 and remember I started in
2012 and in 2012 around May of 2016 I
started noticing weird stuff going on in
the complexes in the hallways and stuff
so I kept everybody on I put out a bolo
be on the lookout right because what
happened was I would come in at the end
of the night and check on the places I
had all electronic locks so once the
girl left I locked the doors
electronic remotely and they all kept
the money whatever we told him to keep
it now it's going check on the place and
make sure everything is clean they
cleaned it up they had a little
procedure to do after they were done
with the shift and I would pick up the
money and go so that may I started
noticing some weird stuff going on you
know I'm always paranoid of course when
you're doing some illegal those looking
around seeing what's going on something
out of our character something out of
place and so we kept an eye out finally
around June June 9th 2016 I saw well a
couple of girls told me they saw when
they were gained into work they saw a
couple of guys on different part of the
complex now these complexes are have a
thousand apartments and five buildings
to this particular complex so I have one
apartment here and when this building
one apartment day I went apartment there
it's funny because they all saw the same
two guys at one point or another in the
hallways
so I said okay I know what's going on
because they were trying really hard to
bust me from like a year and a half on
from 2014 on they've been trying and I
have such a good screening system they
could not penetrates because what they
try to do is they try to bust one girl
and that's how they get in and then that
girl spilled the beans and then that's
it you're done that's why I made sure
that my straining system was you know
tip-top shape so I decided to after four
and a half years I decided that it was
enough now it's going to be too too
close for comfort security wise remember
this is still illegal unfortunately it
should be legal especially at least the
way the way we did it and decided to
shut it down but however I got bored and
in in December I decided to come back as
all these clients had over 900 emails
after like two days because I didn't
tell anybody that we shut down the
clients like where are you at what's
going on I was all over the boards like
there's a as a Yelp for this business
called the erotic review right where
they reviewed that they call them
hobbyists the clients they reviewed the
girls when they go see her so this way
if you one is he you know Jackie you
just go and look it up see what other
guys say about her you know she's good
she worth it you know they give her 1 to
10 all the stuff details
juicy details they call it so we were
all over the boards what happened to is
he found oh my god and I looked at the
main email address there's like over
nine hundred emails just in like two
days right I'm like oh man and they kept
emailing kept emailing and they kept so
I had to get rid of all the former
phones and everything of course for
security purposes finally in December I
decided to come back which was the worst
mistake I've ever made in my life and I
was already being followed and they had
GPS and all my cards they already found
the GPS on and I had three cars and
they're all my cars my girlfriend was a
dentist at the time she didn't know
anything she didn't know my real name
no I didn't tell her anything I was
struggling with it because we were
together three years I'm having this
regular life here meanwhile I'm doing
all this stuff she's thinking I'm doing
this business here and I got this office
here and this and meanwhile I'm doing
this and there's no way I was gonna tell
her right cuz I've been told on before I
wasn't trying to lie to her but I just
can't couldn't tell her I didn't tell
him I relay my had a different ID
different name and I found GPS I took
her cars to my buddy's garage and found
GPS on she had to correspond to GPS on
her car's too I'm like oh man this is
bad so now I was that was faced with a
decision right just like that movie heat
within 30 seconds what Bobby DeNiro said
in 30 seconds and last man if you feel
the heat around the corner you got to go
write something okay should I just take
take the money and run or what should I
do
like man I'm with my girlfriend she got
an eight-year-old I'm having this family
life here you know I'm getting older
that's why these things don't mix if
you're gonna do Sami or not I'm not I'm
not condoning it I'm just saying if you
do so via you cannot have both you can
have your cake and eat it too you cannot
be a Family Guy here and over here
you're you're doing your POV videos and
he's some [ __ ] all day right this is my
friend so I decided not to say anything
but I started again just with my OC fun
website just with the clients I had I
picked like not even a thousand clients
under like 800 clients I said okay those
are the the ones that spent at least 500
to 1500 every time they came you know
our $500 an hour was our minimum but a
lot of them just came you know gave
thousand 1,500 whatever so I kept the
top tier VIP clients and I only had
about 18 girls working and I went down
to like five places or six places I
forgot and kept it a small and I said
you know what I started seeing things
I've seen in front of the Comba here so
it's not worth it I said as of January
31st I said if this doesn't if I don't
feel comfortable body we're gonna shut
it down right and I told some clients
and some girls well guess what happened
January 31st
Here I am walking out of my girlfriend's
house she lived in Ladera Ranch
and by the way you can google my name
this is all over the news right January
31st 2017 I just got back from the gym
looking down the street I saw this SUV
is black SUV I can tell it doesn't
belong there cuz Sheila is in a really
nice area you know I knew I knew who's
what I said oh man and it's all tinted
windows and I could tell from the from
the front I looked I could see people
just sitting in there I'm like oh no
this is not good so I walked in there
the house now what do I do
long story short I walk out about 15
minutes later change clothes I thought I
was gonna matter and get rid of as much
evidence as I can I didn't have that
much in her house and sure enough here
comes 22 23 cops from everywhere get
down this guy over here on the left I
never forget this guy and it's in my
book too that's how I open the book he
said freeze and he had a machine gun
mark and he was so his adrenaline
because they got you know adrenaline
right they get so excited he was shaking
like this I thought he's gonna shoot me
I'm like whoa whoa take it easy man
Here I am I'm getting arrested I'm
supposed to be a nervous right but
unfortunately I'm used to those
situations before right I've been
through SWAT teams and all that stuff
it's in then take it easy you shaking so
hard right now it's gonna be okay
Here I am I'm telling him it's gonna be
okay right do not pull that trigger man
cuz you know though they got he had an
ar-15 or something cuz you know they
obviously I'm look look what we got
going on now right
you're not running you know how do you
know that guy hey get down I'm like it
was like kind of raining a little bit
you know so the ground was wet and I got
my car in front of there the house might
might my thing was I'm gonna get in the
car go to one of my storage units where
I had a little stash of money and go
down south and just chill out you know
go to Rosarito Beach a song is just
chill out you know I had an SL 63 so I'm
like okay I know I can beat him to the
border you know there's three
12-cylinder right and of course I didn't
make it to the car even though it was
like 10 feet away from the front door
but um so I said okay I'll you know
sorry I did I did there
kiss the ground and you know the guys
trying to put the I'll tell you this is
funny story the guys tell him I was 265
right really really big you know I've
always big big size and the guys trying
to put my my arms behind my back and
trying to Hank off me with one handcuff
but it wouldn't go because I was so big
he was like stops right here you know
I'm like man wait trying to do like get
my you know shoulders out of my socket
or something just put another one on
there I'm trying to tell the guy how to
do his job is just put another one on
there man so yeah so another guy he
ended up being the detective Hall he was
the main guy from the human trafficking
task force what happened was I got I got
kind of stuck with the human trafficking
task force and they kept seeing my ads
and they kept seeing how mine is
different than everybody else you got
the upscale backgrounds with these
gorgeous girls and lingerie of course I
fogged out their faces and of course you
use take pictures and you know prepaid
phones and whatever you know every all
the all the safety thing but they had me
on the surveillance for so long and to
be honest with you I can't even tell you
all the details because I never even
looked at my discovery I ended up taking
a deal after four months they were
talking about 78 years they kept every
time he saw an atom the remotely looked
like mine and mind you a lot of our
pictures were stolen which I let people
do that at first I used to get pissed
off I'm like oh no it's okay we had our
pictures in Florida we have the pictures
in Texas and God knows where right and I
let him use our pictures why because it
confuses the the thing right so because
a lot of them use fake pictures so I
ended up from I had a three million
dollar bill with the 1275 1275
attachment meaning he have to show that
every single penny going towards that
bale is coming from legal source so
they're gonna scrutinize every single
penny basically they don't want me out
because I saw guys in there I end up in
Theo lace in Orange County jail I had
guys in there that were in for murder
and they
five or six hundred thousand dollar bail
me know I'm like running an escort
service three million dollars they
didn't want me out so after four months
judge Makino gave me an offer
one a one-time offer because the DA was
not giving me any offers the DA all he
wanted was my list he wanted my list and
he wanted to start charging people
because he charged my own I had a I had
a lawyer my first lawyer call was called
Walter Mitchell who was also a client
and the DA kept telling him in court
listen Your Honor this is this guy is a
client also we can't give you the
discovery that's why I haven't seen my
discovery I went and did my time came
out I still haven't seen my discovery
which is totally legal right but long
story short as soon as Walter recused
himself because of the pressure from the
DA just to give you an idea what kind of
DA it was Walter got it got indicted and
he lost his license right I only had to
do a stay on the case and he kept me and
it really he left me in a really bad
spot I had already paid him and I'm two
weeks away from the speedy trial anyways
long story short he wanted that list I
want the list I want the list I'm
getting sentenced to ten years that I
just you know they found foreign said
they said 469 thousand in that storage
unit I had just a week earlier counted
over eight hundred thousand but it's
okay keep it right keep it no problem
whatever just get me the hell out of
here Rajesh Khanna is horrible
ten years keep all the money they kept a
lot of properties altogether about ten
million dollars worth right
okay keep it all the DA wanted I'm
getting sentenced to ten years I just
give him everything
you know my underwear everything gonna
take it the DA gets out before I get
sentenced right two minutes privates in
it because all but mister shabazz
supposed to give us the list what am I
gonna give you the list I'm taken I just
gave you everything that I have I own
I'm taking ten years in prison for some
it should be illegal and you want me to
give you the list too of people that
trusted me you know I mean I had I mean
I had guys I had two guys from his own
DA's office there were clients
you know that mean I'm like man yeah let
me just go do my tongue get out because
these people trust me I can't do that to
these people they're professionals they
can lose their job they lose their wife
they're gonna get a divorce that god
knows you know so I did my time and you
know when she trusts me I'm not gonna
break that trust so and Here I am how
many years did you do the second time I
did fit eight months on ten years so you
get half time because it's not about in
Vegas you did how many years Oh
31 months when I fought that federal
case or you want anyone in they you 38
38 for the Orange County I got about
almost 10 years in in fighting and
fighting cases and Bs nine months here 6
months here there's no such thing as
easy money it's an incredible story so
looking back do you regret having done
this I'm gonna tell you right now if
this was legal if I can get a license
right now this is what I'll be doing
because this is what I know how to do
yeah this is what you do this is what I
do yeah you know this is like you
clearly know how to make it this is how
you know I yeah yeah everybody's happy
they talk to some girls I guess for my
co-defendant she told me I'm by the way
they grabbed her too dad a you know
insult to injury they grabbed her she
don't even know my real name she had to
put up a $500,000 bail it was a million
went down to five hundred thousand she
stayed in jail for ten this is a fifty
some year old lady that's a dentist has
their own practice in Ladera Ranch she
was a dentist for twenty seven years at
that time her face her mugshot is right
if you google my name her mug shot was
right next to mine all over the place
right now she lost automatic she lost
over 30 percent percent of our clientele
and it took her a year and a half to get
the thing dismiss because they could not
believe that it was only me doing all
this whole thing they could not believe
they cannot how there's no way there's
no way one person can do everything so
that's why they grabbed her and then you
she had not do with it but they just
could not believe that this one person
can do all this you know cuz we're
bringing in over five or six million a
year yeah gross
was a stressful of course man most of it
right but I know aside from just even if
it was legal will be tres stressful
because he got girls you got to deal
with them sometimes they got issues you
got a babysit basically your glorified
babysitter sometimes you got two guys
sometimes with issues you got you know
just that's life you know was it was a
craziest story you can share you must
have seen a lot of crazy stuff oh my god
specially in Vegas and this is why I can
tell you a couple stories but the reason
why I don't allow drugs in this business
is because I hired this twin they were
the only twins online real twins they
were young was 21 cute like 85 pounds or
whatever anyways I did not know they
were hooked on oxy now I sold him as Sin
City twins so if you want to see them
you have to see them together now of
course the guys are really thought that
these girls are sisters that they're
going to do things together with the
client come on you know it was a lot of
perversion out there right but let him
think whatever it's all implied let him
think whatever they thing it was a
thousand dollars per girl per hour and
they had to book two hours so if you
want to see him it's four thousand
minimum right so these girls were making
over ten grand a week just going on four
or five dates you know I did not know
that you had a oxycontin problem because
at the time oxy was like 80 bucks a pill
they liked those pills whatever crushed
or whatever they did now the more money
they make guess what happens the more
drugs they make fast forward about six
months I'm reading remember I told you
about the erotic review that the yelp of
this business I'm reading a review
because I kept track of everything and
this real good client he wrote a review
I'm like he never told me anything but
he said he is on a date with them one
girl is going down in him she fell
asleep and the other girl was reading
his his wet bar and his snacks and stuff
part of the suite right I'm like oh no
this is not good so I let him go right
well six months later after I fired them
six months later I realized they have a
really big problem with oxycontin one of
them was found at Orly
is she Oh deed unfortunately passed away
yeah what makes it crazy is a year later
her sister comes to me the one that the
surviving sister and she wants a job at
80 pounds looked all [ __ ] up on
crystal meth and God knows what else
she's on chill totally [ __ ] up I'm
like are you freaking crazy you just
buried your sister now you think I'm
gonna give you a job look at you 80
pounds like skeleton it's crazy man but
I'll tell you this I had clients a lot
of clients they were like straight sex
addicts I had clients they'll come in
every day sometimes twice a day I had
this one client who was a surgeon right
he was coming with his scrubs come in
jump in five seconds you worked for UCLA
he's one of the main surgeon there at
the hospital not even hey sometimes you
have blood I'm like the girls like oh my
god this guy's like it's okay just
forget about it let him make sure he
takes shower first but I had one other
client I was a doctor right for some
reason doctors are really really pervy
this doctor would come in once a month
and he wanted me to line him up he say
okay who's next
he would go from here to here T remember
each call head was in their own place
like this okay go see Cindy go see Nikki
go see you know Jen go see six seven
girls in one day I'm sure he's on viagra
but viagra doesn't do anything but keeps
you hard that doesn't change how fast
you come right and this guy once a month
man boom boom different locations yeah
in the same day you drive around
yeah he'll just go from one to the other
today I'm like man this guy and he was
like he's like 60 years old but yeah we
had a lot of we had some guys with I
didn't do it early a lot of fetishes
because I don't like fetishes it gets
weird you know what I mean
it gets really weird with them so we
don't really do fetish but some guys you
know like if it's if it's something
light like this guy like to go dress up
like a like a schoolgirl or or soon
outfit hey you know you know step on me
or some something some light stuff I'll
let him do it but other than that
you know the ones that want you to squat
on a glass table and do your number
about it no we're not gonna do that it's
too much it's a crazy story ready thank
you so much for sharing it of course
good luck with your book and where that
takes you
oh thank you yeah madam Suzanne it's on
Amazon everywhere but J hopefully we'll
turn it into a series or a movie is a
fascinating story that goes on it goes
on man it's I could look at the top for
20 days and still have more stuff like
this going on as we speak today you know
you're no longer in in the business but
are there other people that are do you
know what they and the thing about this
is they cannot stop this right it's it's
human nature manager men are wired a
certain way that they like to procreate
so they don't have they could be married
and I had a lot of clients tell me this
because they got really close personal
you know they some of them would like to
talk to me and they'll tell you all
their their you know problems or
whatever and they all love their wives
unconditionally and they don't want to
lose their wife but it's just that we
really believe this after years in this
business we're wired a certain way where
you know there's love and there's sex
and they can go out and have sex with an
escort and go right to their there and
it doesn't mean they don't love their
wife is just that men are wired a little
differently
some women who like that too I had a lot
of girls that were like that - like what
straight [ __ ] and they would do it
for free but they were getting paid so
they didn't care they loved it they'll
do 20 guys a day no problem you know but
uh I'm sure it's going on of course it's
going on even with kovat 19 you know I
did a little research for the book it's
still going on but I can tell you one
thing it's never gonna be the way I did
it because you know unfortunately in
this business lying cheating beating
switch you know conniving is part of it
I just didn't want to do it that way it
wasn't it wasn't Who I am so I refused
to do it I refused to rip the clients
off I refused to rip the girls off now
don't get me wrong you know I will help
her get as much money as she can from a
sugar daddy which is a whole different
thing and it's in the book but so that
book yeah but yeah all right Freddie
thank you so much for sharing your story
of course mark any very very interesting
any time thank you
sure
you